sort of talking session of the boot camp
is more speed talks and we are happy to
uh kick it off with Alex gillo um from
uh lip six I guess we just had a
discussion about why that is the name um
telling us about cryptographic
applications of quantum error correcting
codes go for it so yeah this is not a
talk where I'm talking about like
anxiety new results is more to give an
overview why where Quantum codes can be
used on top of everything that you have
seen so far
and just to start with it
[Music]
oops so let's give a step back and talk
a bit about Quantum and crypto and uh
yeah I think the first like Quantum got
a lot of attention when actually people
realize that Quantum helps malicious
parties so then we have to come up with
now with new assumptions that are
quantum resistant and this is one way of
code like also to connect codes with uh
Quantum is try to find a new post
quantum cryptographic uh Primitives
sorry cryptographic assumptions but the
good thing is that Quantum also helps
honest parties so we can use Quantum
Resources to achieve new cryptography
and this is the focus of my talk how to
yeah how to do new cryptography but now
sending cubits over a Quantum
Channel and yeah as I said I I want to
talk like very generally how Quantum
codes can help to to build cryptographic
Primitives and I'll talk about a lot of
old results and a few new
results uh and uh yeah dat is to keep it
very I don't know light uh it will be a
a brief overview of everything and I'm
happy to discuss things later if people
are
interested so let's dive into the first
applications is about authentication so
um like uh the Quant authentication is
how to how to how can Alice send a
Quantum message to Bob and Bob is sure
that uh he received a message from Alice
and nobody tampered with that Quantum
message
um it so what we want is that Bob when
he received this message that's encoded
by Alice that he decides that uh like
someone tempered with it or uh it was
the original
message
um briefly okay yeah maybe to be too
many details but the idea is that
Quantum codes allow us to do that so we
assume here for example that Alis and
Bob they share some common uh common key
and this allows them to
uh to uh authenticate Quantum messages
as well and actually this is not really
Quantum so the same class analog also
works it's just to an um an example of
things that do quanti like how Quantum
codes uh they have the same behavior as
classical codes when you're in the
classical
level and how does this uh scheme uh
work so they as I said they share a key
so and we see the key as some bases so
like all these zero bases or the Hadar
bases like the plus minus bases and they
share a bunch of random mids that I call
here a and x and they also share a
random permutation on two Lambda
cubits and the idea of the encoding is
the following so first Alice will encode
her her Quantum State using a Quantum
Code and then apply the quantum version
of One Time Pad so she'll fully hide the
the the information about what Quantum
State you have there
and she also creates uh like this random
if you know what it is a random bb84
states which are just random 01 plus
minus State and she permutes everything
so it will be uh this stat is what we
call a trap trap cubits uh and the idea
is that she will mix like this encoded
state with the strap cubits and permut
all of them and when Bob Bob knows all
the private information so the idea is
that everything that IED here is
reversible so Bob can just undo the
peration undo this Quantum one time pad
and check trap cubits so Bob has full
information what he should be receiving
and the key point that you can use this
idea to like all this techniques or all
these tools to show that the straps
prevent any malicious part in the middle
to heavily disturb the quantum State and
the air correction here will help us to
provide this light one so uh the idea is
that these two have to work together so
just the traps are not enough to to to
certify authentication and the AR
correction here is just uh to uh uh
prevent like small modification on the
quantum State as I said this is just a
warmup like everything here also works
classically if you you think about
random strings and a class correcting
code so this is not new it's just as I
said an example of how this
quanti
um but now uh let me switch gears and
talk about some things that are more
interesting which is quantum secret
sharing and for those who don't know
what secret sharing is I think she she
might talk a bit about it but let me uh
briefly present it in ciruit Sharing we
have a trusted dealer that she wants to
to share a given Quantum State among
multiple parties so she based on this
Quantum State row she G gives shares of
States Sigma to for example here eight
parties and what you want is that up to
K colluding parties cannot retrieve the
original state role but if you have K
Prime colluding parties they they they
can retrieve this the quantum State Ro
so it's a secet sharing of a Quantum
State
okay um and as Chim might uh
mentioned um if you can correct correct
up to some uh T errors then it turns out
that the density Matrix on T cubits is
independent of the encoded States one
can show that if it was uh not if it was
dependent somehow you can distinguish
Quantum States so it' be collaps in them
and uh this would violate no cloning
theorem and therefore people realize in
99 that these Quantum in COD there are
good enough Quantum secr Shing
skins uh and the idea is just the dealer
in codes with Quant correction and send
cubits to everybody and uh and this
directly gives some chart of uh secret
sharing
scheme but okay what I want to talk more
abouts that actually we can uh go one
step further and uh not only Quant
arting codes they have this property
there are secret of secret sharing but
you can also uh U this property also
holds if you apply local operations on
this quing
codes uh so the idea is that uh not only
we can uh like local parts of quantum
correcting code U are are the same like
they're independent of the coded of the
message of the quantum message but also
operations on them are also independent
and this was a very uh key tool that uh
we needed to prove Zer knowledge
protocols for pro proof systems and
later to to qma so this is the Quantum
version of the uh like the celebrated
result that introduced Z knowledge
proofs in multipro interactive Pro
system
and this is uh the quum version of the
sigma protocol for like zero knowledge
protocol for three coloring for those
who who are familiar with that so I'd
like just to zoom in a bit how we used
to prove the air corra in C to prove
this
result a quick question in secret
sharing you require also that usually if
there are enough people then they can
recover the SE set by the same that be
possible no because you know if you have
if you have you shouldn't be able to
tell anything one more in threshold
secret sharing oh so so it won't be t t+
one there are some K and K Prime such
that up to K you cannot and uh starting
from K Prime from K Prime you can so if
you can correct up to T errors if I give
you T in N minus t cubits you can
recover the rest and you can decode but
you can decode with any any sufficient
number by again by noing wouldn't that
mean that no no the is it this number
has to be at least in over
two and and then you're done okay yeah
there's this thing one of the bounds
like you need at least 10 over two
parties to be able to
decode okay uh so yeah let me uh zoom in
a bit how we use uh
or the technical tool that allowed us to
prove uh like the simple Zer knowledge
protocols for QA and by the way qma is
just a version of NP so just think about
NP but where everything is quantum the
quantum proof a Quantum Quantum
verification and so
on and
uh the uh the way that you prove this Z
knowledge uh protocol for for this uh
for qma was studying this problem called
consistence of local Den matrices and
this is what what some people call the
quantum marginal problem so the problem
that that we have here is uh suppose
that you're you're given description of
pieces of a Quantum state so we have a
classical description of a bunch of
parties parts of the quantum State and
your question is is there a global
Quantum State that's consistent with all
of these parties all of these
parts okay so what you want to the input
to the problem is just the classical
description of reduced andm matrices and
as I said is there a Quantum State such
that the this GL Global Quantum state is
consistent with the local parties or
there at least one of these parts that
that is uh rather far from from all
Quantum
States and U proved in uh 2006 that this
problem is contained is quantum version
of NP and he also shows some sort of Q
harness for it but only with three
reductions but uh the problem is yeah
two reductions are not good enough for
example for having zero knowledge
protocols and uh this is uh the step
that uh like and BRB and I we we took to
to to be able to prove this Z knowledge
protocol is showing the QA harness of
this problem under uh carp
reductions uh and this and okay yeah I
don't have time so the idea is that this
uh for to proven this result uh we
heavily use some properties of quantum
error correction let me just uh finish
with there are other many other
applications of quantum codes in or
classo and Quantum codes in in Quantum
cryptography and let let me finish with
that
a quick question while the next speaker
sets
up there are no
questions in the secret sharing
algorithm like only one person can
reconstruct the secret so in secret
sharing like only one like so even if
three of us split it up two people put
it together only one person gets the
state at the
end does that in the CL it's course
different than the classical case within
the group who shared we all get the
state um how does that affect other
parts of protocols now I think it will
depend how the how the protocols compos
so I think I think this these definition
is that everybody says that the shares
together to someone and this person has
theate that's
it so there's some protocols where like
in a second round other people would
want to use and now they can't there's
only one Quantum State yeah there is
just one
this comes from no
yeah we can take the further questions
offline and let's thank
Al so our next speaker is Gabrielle Beck
who's going to tell us about apparently
a single New Direction for applying air
crating code techniques to crypto sorry
thanks I realized that my title was too
broad uh this talk will probably be a
little bit more informal than the last
one I'm not going to
oh yes yes thank you so much
sorry I don't know
why um Can can you hear me
okay can you hear me all right okay cool
thanks sorry this talk is going to be a
little bit more informal than the last
one I'm not going to spam you with a
bunch of math but I'm going to basically
introduce sort of a new problem setting
in which uh code seem to be like a
useful tool and then we'll end sort of
with a bunch of like open questions that
I would actually like prefer a lot of
help from people in here on okay so uh
right so I'm going to talk about one uh
New Direction for applying error coding
techniques uh to cryptography and the
main setting I'm going to be concerned
with here is a relatively new technology
uh which I'm going to call like tracking
tags or tags and so what a tracking tag
is is it's actually just a low power and
cheap uh device that will let you track
belongings so this includes things like
uh you could put them on your luggage on
bikes on like a car those sorts of
things uh and tracking tags are made
currently by a bunch of different uh
companies so this includes tile Apple
and Samsung they look something like
this the most popular thing that you may
oh my gosh sorry that was a mistake okay
the most uh popular uh one of these is
probably the air tag which is the one in
the upper left corner here um and so tag
tracking tags are interesting for a lot
of reasons uh but one of the main ones
is because they're so uh low power they
don't have access to a lot of
functionality which means uh they don't
have like a GPS inside of them they
don't have the ability to connect to the
internet all they have is basically uh
they communicate with other devices over
Bluetooth so like very like near
communication is the only thing that
they're capable of doing and so like
this seems kind of weird right because I
just said you can use these things to
basically track items but they also
can't communicate with the original
owner so like what is actually going on
here um well when you purchase like some
kind of tracking tag and you put it like
on um like a device and you step away
from it what actually happens is this
device does the only thing it knows how
to do which is it begins sort of
broadcasting packets locally and there's
a bunch of like uh devices that are part
of what is called a volunteer network
which are listening for these signals
and this volunteer network is basically
owned by the person who uh like uh makes
the tracking tax so these broadcasts get
sent out the volunteers collect them
these volunteers will then form location
reports based upon the broadcast and
along with location data that these
devices have upload it to some Central
server and then like you as the owner of
the tag will communicate with the
central server uh to get the reports so
that's basically like how at a very high
level um a uh like you can use these
devices to attract things okay so uh
this is all well and good but like as a
cryptographer as a security and privacy
person typically when I see systems like
this or like proposals for things like
this I ask okay what can go wrong like
are there any sorts of privacy concerns
that might exist in these sorts of
systems uh and there are two main ones
that come to mind uh one of them is
potentially a track risk so uh the way
that this works is you know say I have
um put this tag on a bike I'm you know
riding around a campus somewhere maybe
like I step away from the tag it starts
submitting broadcasts I then get on my
bike go somewhere else step away and
then you know more broadcasts are
emitted if parties can link these two
things together that's kind of bad right
because you've learned some like
non-trivial information on me and over
time like you can lose a lot of privacy
this way so we don't want it to be
possible for honest tag users to be
tracked by anyone out in the
wild and then one other major concern
here that I'm sure a lot of people have
probably thought about maybe in this
context is that you know basically there
seems to be a pretty big uh like
stocking concern that is there could be
a malicious you know U tag user who
doesn't use tags to track objects but
instead uses them to track people and we
would like to prevent this um at the
very least what we would like um is for
the parties who are being tracked to
somehow be able to notice that they're
being tracked and then like have steps
taken so that they can do a sort of a
like so that they can identify the tag
and recover it or something and this
last one has many sort of real examples
um and it's kind of a a really big
problem so in these location tracking
networks I'm going to say there are like
two things we would really like first we
would like to come up with like
constructions of those tracking networks
that are have privacy for honest users
but also somehow provide protection
against stalkers uh and this seems kind
of difficult right for an obvious reason
um so stocking victims really would like
to tell when they have seen multiple
broadcasts from the same Tech but like
that's exactly the tracking adversary
right I just told you that we don't want
it to be the case that like if I see um
like a like that's this is a privacy
concern basically for honest users if
you can link together broadcast from the
same teag so we're going to take
advantage maybe of a slightly strange
Assumption of so imagine like I have a
tracking tag and I like place it on you
if I do that within any like given fixed
window of time you're going to see most
of the broadcasts probably that are made
by the tracking teag right because the
only reason you wouldn't is if there's
like some kind of Hardware failure you
will always be in that Bluetooth like
communication range so like most of the
broadcasts are going to be seen by a
stalking victim however we're going to
make the Assumption here that the
tracking adversary has a much more
limited window of view and what this
means is basically like we can come up
with systems where like if you see a
majority of the broadcast you can do
recovery but if you only see a small
subsection then that person or like that
tag is completely private so that's what
we're going to use so um this this has
like a formal cryptographic definition
that's actually kind of based on secret
sharing which was discussed earlier but
I'm only going to Define this really
Loosely right now because I'm sure I
don't have enough time but yeah so
basically the main thing we want to do
is construct like a pair of algorithms
one of which produces all those
broadcasts which I showed earlier and
then um another algorithm that will
basically allow us to do detection if
you like get a list of broadcasts so
those are like the two the two
ingredients we need um and we want
particular properties of these
algorithms so first one Loosely stated
is about the detection algorithm so like
if a single tag supplies at least some
number of broadcasts we want it to be
detected with high probability whatever
that means it could mean like I get an
identifier that for the tag or something
else but it should be detectable uh and
the second thing we want is that for a
sub like a set of at most K broadcasts
from a single tag those should be
unlinkable and that's like the Privacy
property I was talking about earlier
what it essentially means is that you
know if I only give you like three let's
say broadcasts from this one particular
device it should be indistinguishable
from if I gave you all from another
device or even like some other
distribution of Secrets From Another
party like all of these things should be
indistinguishable at a high level you
shouldn't be able to tell anything about
the distribution of those K
values
okay right so you know like from a
really high level perspective like if
you sit here and like maybe you stare at
it for a long time it seems like this is
a really good like a setting for some
sort of like coding Theory problem right
because um if we look at a fixed window
of time all these parties are producing
about the same number of broadcasts and
this like single sorry all of these tags
are producing about the same number of
broadcasts and then we have a single
party who gets some collection of
symbols from those parties so like maybe
you can imagine each of these parties is
like outputting a code word that is
consist like consists of a bunch of
symbols and the bottom party is getting
some symbols from those code words and
has to do like some listic coding
algorithm or something to do recovery so
this is like uh yeah so this is like a
good way to think about it maybe however
like if you try to think about sort of
the unlinkability property that we need
and in terms of a lot of existing code
Construction it seems like there's a lot
of tension between these two ideas like
a lot of simple things that you might
attempt to do won't exactly work because
you'll be violating the unlinkability
property so it's this is not to say that
we can't come up with things it's just
that like you have to be like very
careful on how you do things and also we
don't you yeah H as cryptographers we
don't usually think about things from
this perspective so like it's sort of um
an open question right now like even
what unlinkability means sort of in a
coding Theory sense but yeah so I I
guess what I'm just trying to impress is
like there is a way to view this from
that perspective but I can only tell you
the perspective that I know which is not
this one entirely um
so sorry basically uh within um how much
time do I have left by the way uh about
30 seconds okay yes all right so I knew
this would happen okay so basically
within our work we do show that actually
you can achieve this unlinkability
property from like a family of types of
read Solomon codes so basically you have
every single tag choose a random
polinomial of some given degree and
output like random uh like evaluations
at random points along with the x
coordinate and this is good enough for
unlinkability you can do this also with
IRS code so inter Le read Solomon where
all of these polinomial are uh
independent as well these constructions
will satisfy unlinkability uh to do to
do recovery you need to do some kind of
list decoding algorithm so you can use
standard listed coding algorithms for
this uh the only problem is basically uh
for for our scheme like the parameters
tnk which I was talking about earlier
the privacy and Recovery parameters
those kind of depend on the fraction of
Errors the code can correct from uh and
what in in an ideal you would want
privacy to be as high as possible and
like the detection to be as close to
that as possible and what this would
really imply is that you need to be able
to list decode up to capacity for these
things
so right so we come up with a
construction based on Guru Swami Sudan
but it's like it's it's okay for the
parameters that we want and because we
showed earlier that IRS codes also
satisfy unlinkability if we had a good
decoder for that we can do potentially
better and that's also what this second
bullet point is here there's question
marks in there because I am not sure if
this is even a new algorithm this is
also one that can only recover heris
that bound we know like better than that
Bound for other types of codes and for
IRS codes you can uh like somewhat meet
that Bound for random errors so this
this is like
a that bullet points doing a lot of
heavy lifting and we show basically that
our constructions uh are also efficient
so I think I went way way over but I
have a lot of
questions basically that I about like
the the kind of work that we did
regarding this project I don't have the
time I think to explain what any of
these are but if you uh if you want to
talk to me about this afterwards that
would be really
appreciated so
[Music]
apologies
[Applause]
yes so maybe in the interest of time I
see there are some questions maybe we
can take them offline just to keep it
moving um yeah so the next speaker
can
so hi all right so yeah so next up we
have a crystal
um sorry Crystal Moen um telling us
about
isogenes um sorry this has nothing to do
with our correcting codes I just saw a
form that said hey sign up for a talk so
um thank you so much for bearing with me
and um yeah so I'm here because this
Workshop has a lot of things that are
that I like the computer science and
math and number Theory and graph Theory
um and I saw J actually has a lot of
these things so first what is
soy we have to talk about elliptic
curves first so an elliptic curve is
usually unlike um the previous talk I
apologized for math um so they have
genus one elliptic curves with a
specified base point and each such curve
um is written as the locus of p^2 over a
cubic equation when I say cubic equation
I mean y^2 = X Cub plus yada um and then
there's usually Aline at Infinity so
when scaled appropriately ellips a curve
has a a cubic polinomial form which is
expressing this wire Strauss equation so
we go from this form on the top to this
form which is a wi stous equation and
usually the shortcut for it the shorter
wire St equation is expresses um y^2
equals x Cub plus a X plus b so um when
we say genus 1 this is kind of a meme on
the internet so genus one one hole genus
two two holes Etc um a topologist
morning routine and um when we say a
base point we should we mean that we
have this o equals 0 one0 so at some
point our curve goes to Infinity um and
this so it means that it's parallel to
the y-axis which is usually a
characteristic of elliptic curves and so
when we draw elliptic curves it's
usually some point even though we can't
see it here that goes to
infinity and um there are generally two
types of elliptic curv the cusp type and
the node type as well so how do we make
isogen some of these things so um we
have a pairing misogyny is a pairing
group um that is defined as a projective
map between this genus one which we
spoke about the one hole from E to e
Prime so it has to be subjective have a
finite kernel and is a group
homomorphism and has an curve defined on
this short wire St equation that we
spoke about so there's also a dual
misogyny which means that we have a
homomorphism in the opposite direction
so we have one going to and one going
from so that we have a map called Fe
from E1 to E2 that is a non-constant
isogeny of degree M and then there's an
ex uh unique isogeny Fe Prime that's
going from E2 to
E1 so um this gives us these properties
so that we get this separable m map
which allows us to prove up by ejection
which we use we we identify this by
ection using something called Val's
formula and so um isogenes start from
this elliptic curve of super singular
which is usually denoted e Subzero and
then we get this elliptic curve pairing
which generates this large random
expander graph um of it's called a
expander graph of ranagen properties so
these properties make a walk along a
path appear random to an onlooker and
supposedly according to the
mathematicians this makes our um
encryption ISO based encryption Quantum
safe so what does ISO based cry
encryption in terms of a protocol look
like I will show a picture of uh TIY
Helman so this is a classical DIY Helman
in which Alice which is a picks a secret
integer that she doesn't reveal to
anyone and so does Bob so we call these
A and B and then Alice sends to Bob the
computed value of this function which is
g to the^ of a mod P and Bob does the
same and then we represent their where
they can identify that they set the
correct message to each other by this
communative diagram so G to the^ of a b
should be the same as G to the ba so
when we try to do this with elliptic
curves we find that we can't actually do
this so what we have to do instead is we
use this um from the e Subzero which is
our starting curve we create this isoton
which is
generated by um Computing Feast of one
from the image gve of e sub one which is
our Alice Alice computation and then we
have an misogyny from E
sub2 and as well as Fe sub1 P2 and Fe
sub1 Q2 which are actually showed here
which are the basis of the torsions of
that e Subzero and then we send um the
information so Alla sends their
information to Bob and Bob sends the
information to Alice and so Alice
computes this corresponding isogeny upon
receiving this corresponding pie and Q
from Bob and he computes his part and
then they look at their uh corresponding
isogenes
fe11 just this one and
fe12 and then based on that there's
something that's calculated called a
Jane variance and that's where you get
the commutative property so these two
J12 and j21 should be the same so why
would anyone want to make cryptography
out of these things they seem really
convoluted so in 2017 NIS started this
postquantum standardization and isogenes
actually s um survived three rounds of
scrutin and testing
Unfortunately they didn't really go that
much further so so there these recent
attacks that happened in 2022 and
actually somebody asked me so Gabrielle
asked me about this before I give the
talk I actually have a sticker on my
laptop that has the it's like a those
tombstones that has the starting date of
the isogenes and the ending date
2022 um and so uh there are two recent
attacks that happened in 2022 these are
the papers by Krick and the crew and
Damen Robert that talk about how they're
able to basically break it in up within
within four to six minutes and
eight hours 15 minutes 20 hours 37
minutes respectively on a laptop which
is pretty bad right so what does that
mean for
isogenes well it is to be noted that um
the attack is on Sid which is the one
the one that I showed not Seaside and
there's also another protocol call uh
ski sign that's also safe so not all of
isogenies is broken there are just some
parts of the protocol that need to be
fixed um that being said I think um
there's also another hash function
that's called The Charles Goran lter
hash function and what the problem with
both of these protocols is that you need
someone to start the vertex so we spoke
about a trusted having a trusted party
both protocols rely on this trusted
party who has information about the
colel extra auxiliary information
essentially and with that information
it's possible that an adversary can
break the protocol so that being said um
this is a similar hash function that has
that has also been broken that needs to
be fixed and it relies on expander
graphs um
so I just wanted to say that part of my
being here is um that when I first
started in 20122 with my advisers
Christal who's in mathematics and my
adviser Joe I was very skeptical about
the whole spog graphs and postquantum
cryptography thing and I think that
there's a lot more information that
could be learned particularly because so
this is my um pcmi T-shirt from 2022 the
the theme was quantum Computing and the
year before that it was computational
number theory in
2022 all of the mathematicians showed up
to go to computational number Theory so
I knew everyone there and then in
2023 about four of us showed up so
there's something that's not happening
between people making postquantum
cryptography and people working in
Quantum Computing and so I'm here
because I think there's a lot that can
be learned by those two communities
coming together especially if we're on
the on the mathematics side making
talking about hardness properties
theoretically and the quantum people are
saying well we don't quite agree with
your with your um so that's kind of why
I'm hearing um yeah
thanks
one question while the next speaker sets
[Music]
up no questions I guess let's thank
Crystal
again while I set up I guess I can
already uh comment that there does seem
to be a bit of a you know a crypto theme
to the last few talks so if that does
interest you there is a crypto reading
group so please look out for that on
zulip I'm currently uh soliciting you
know uh feedback on what the best time
to do it would be so any let's start
this up
here you set up I can introduce you next
up we have Nick R from the University of
Amsterdam may not have slides well I
don't have I don't have slides in fact
what I did was uh I wrote some stuff
down on my iPad I was planning to you
know just uh write it on the board then
I realized wait what's the point I can
just do this so uh yeah So the plan is
to talk about uh a topic that I've
recently got interested in called uh
smoothing codes and I think it's kind of
a nice topic for a coding Theory a
audience because it might not be a
problem that you've looked at before but
first of all it might have some
connections to uh some stuff that I
guess Henry and I have been talking
about you know we proving that read
Muller codes achieve um you know this
sort of threshold phenomenon somehow the
point at which you get close to one is
kind of related to the point at which
you smooth the code um and also it's you
know pretty easy to understand uh the
problem so hopefully I can explain it in
the 10 or so minutes I have okay so what
is the basic idea so I give you some
code C and some sort of error
distribution e so you can just think of
this as some sort of distri you know
like a random vector and what I want to
be able to prove to you is that you know
if if I take a random code word and add
you know some noise to it according to
this error distribution um
I want this thing to look roughly
uniform
right um this is my cryptographer
notation so forgive me if you don't like
it but you know this this just notes a
uniformly random code word um another
way to perhaps say this if you prefer is
I could just imagine looking at my eror
distribution and modding out by the code
and I just want to you know argue that
this is
uniform okay and you know if you want to
be precise let's say you know I want to
prove that in the total variation
distance or statistical distance
whatever you like to call it what half
time1 Norm you know it's a it's a very
very small I don't worry too much about
the precise
modification good supp far I guess I
don't have a lot of time but I think
it's still nice to question of course
like bounded adversar like is it a
comption there's no there's no adversary
at the moment yeah everything is just I
just have two distributions good okay so
what is sort of the question here okay
see what's the motivation here first
things first so why do I why am I
interested in this well um some extent
it's in order to create uh you know it's
a natural Avenue towards proving a worth
case to aage case reduction so what am I
talking about here so we can imagine
sort of a worst case decoding problem
which I'll call wdp with you know these
three parameters NK and W and I guess
throughout the talk you'll I always get
confused when I ever I have matrices and
vectors so I like to draw them as shapes
so I keep track of what the right
dimensions are so what is my input here
you could just think of it as like a
generator Matrix and then some Target
Vector y and you know it's the decoding
problem right so you know you imagine
your Bob uh you and Alice agreed uh that
you're going to use the generator Matrix
G to encode your message and your Bob
and you receive this Vector y so the
prise is first of all that your channel
wasn't too mean so basically your vector
y is at say at most you know Hamming
distance W from some genuine code word
which is you know always of the form
generator Matrix times a message and
your goal is just to recover the message
or actually equivalently if you like if
you recover the error that's also
sufficient because then you just
subtract the error off from from the Y
that you received and then you can
invert The Matrix to find the the
message
M fair enough this is nothing fancy this
is the classic problem of course you
know for worst case matricies we already
know back from you know 1978 or so uh I
don't want to say too much about this
because I'm afraid I might say something
that might be false depending on the
exact parameters but you know broadly
speaking this is a very hard problem and
even NP hard uh you know for most
parameter
reges good good but now of course for
cryptography uh the hardness of a worst
case problem doesn't actually buy you
anything because you know cryptography
the first thing you need to do is
randomly sample a key and you know so
there's already some Randomness involved
and then you sort of natural will create
average case problems so you need
actually that your problem is hard even
if your inputs are randomly sampled so
even if we all agree it's hard to solve
uh decoding in the worst case you know
we still want to uh be convinced that um
this is hard to solve as also in the
average
case and well okay there's a lot of
people have tried to solve this problem
over the years you know there are some I
think there even some like scoreboards
up you know you can actually look up
online to see what are the biggest
possible biggest uh you know decoding
problems that people have managed to
solve so far but you know maybe here i'
like to give some sort of theoretical
evidence that this problem is in De hard
and you know somehow when you deal with
this average case problem it's uh quite
nice to switch to this um Oracle based
problem called learning parity with
noise um and how is this one usually
described well here we have some sort of
fixed Oracle that is given to us and
kind of embedded in this Oracle is some
secret Vector s okay and this Vector s
has length
K and you know what I'd like to
essentially do in the end is determine
this uh this uh secret Vector but you
know the Oracle is somewhat unreliable
so whenever I ask it for um you know
whatever I press a button say the Oracle
will talk to me and it will tell me you
know first of all some random Vector a
and then it'll give me the inner product
of a with the secret s which is great
but it also of course you know maybe
with probability P or you know let's say
0.1 it'll flip the output on me and so
this addition is modul 2 for
Simplicity okay so this is basically you
could imagine you know say if I take you
know n samples from my um Oracle and I
stack them up into a matrix this would
just generate a uniformly random Matrix
and then you know if I look at all of
the everything I receive that would like
and stack them up that would give me
like a vector y so this is basically an
average case pro version of the decoding
problem the only real subtle difference
is that the you know the rate or
whatever of the problem is not fixed at
priori I can keep on asking for more and
more samples that I want you know say
within polinomial time but uh morly it's
a it's a it's a nice problem to look
at everything clear so far cool I
probably should have checked the time
before I started but um about five
minutes okay good so keep that in mind
um so what would I love to prove it' be
something like you know suppose that the
worst case decoding problem is hard then
so is the learning parody with noise
problem and to make this um interesting
the challenge would be that I would like
to you know start from in some sense um
the most conservative assumption
possible so for the you know if uh the
um Target uh decoding radius that I'm
aiming for is W you know this problem
gets harder and harder the larger W is
of course if W equals one I mean I can
solve this problem in you know linear
time I just try flipping each bit and
seeing which one is correct but you know
once W is like super poly logarithmic
let say super logarithmic I guess you
know log squ n let's say that's already
uh to the the best of our knowledge
cannot be solved in polinomial time but
anyways you know making W bigger and
bigger makes uh means that I'm making a
more conservative assumption like I'm
assuming a harder problem is indeed hard
um and then I like to prove that you
know some other problem is hard and I'd
like to you know prove that the
conceptually easiest problem possible is
hard right so if I make p really small
you know um you know as P gets smaller
it should be easier and easier to solve
this LPN problem so you know from a
cryptographer perspective if I want to
you know have a hard problem I want the
seemingly you know easiest problem
possible to be hard
okay so that's what we want now how
could we do this there's a very natural
reduction coming from uh I guess a work
by braer Yi votan and Daniel licks this
was in 2019 it might have been around
before but um it's uh it's very natural
thing to do so what I want to do I need
to create you know some sort of
reduction so I want to solve the worst
case decoding problem with the
assumption that I have some sort of
algorithm that say I you know I have
blackbox Oracle access to that solves
the LPN problem okay so what is so you
know what any reasonable reduction we'll
start off by saying okay run this
algorithm a and then of course this
algorithm a is going to run along and at
some point it's G to want to press its
button and ask for an oracle ask it's
Oracle what you know um you know for a
for a transmission or whatever so I
noted this by you know this sort of
question mark Here and Now how should I
respond as you know the you know as the
one who wants to solve this case
decoding problem well what I'm first
going to do is sample some Vector R
according to what I'm going to call a
smoothing distribution so it'll be clear
in a second what this uh smoothing
distribution should be and then I need
to respond by you know sending back you
know a vector of length k and a ve and
this like a single bit okay and the
vector of length K well I set things up
nicely so if I do sort of this uh do you
know I guess I need to multiply from the
left here so I'll end up with a vector
of length K when I do R * G and this is
sort of more like my uh the vector a
sort of that we expect from this um LPN
sample here okay and now to generate
sort of this uh other bit
here I'm just going to Output the
dotproduct of R and Y okay and where
again Y is like the vector that I'm
trying to
decode so why is this a good idea well
if we break up y based on our assumption
you know it's of the form you know some
sort of code word plus um some noise
vector v here
and you know associativity I can move
things around or I guess no I'm not
using associativity I'm using distri
distributivity oh yeah and associativity
here anyways so I can regroup it so that
this part here is indeed exactly exactly
the thing that I called a above here
right so this looks like a and now you
know my in one case you know I want to
recover the message M this is basically
like the secret s for my LPN sample and
now R.V here well this is just some
bit okay so this essentially looks like
LPN sample there's there's some issues
here like first of all um um it's not
like usually with LPN you need that the
bit B is independent from the sampling
of a but you know if you look at it here
they both depend on the same underlying
Vector R so okay this Independence might
not exist in practice that's not usually
not the big problem the main requirement
that we have to hit is that we need this
first um this first thing to look
uniform right because the only guarantee
I have is that this algorithm a solves
LPN and the LPN is you know the LPN
problem is St in such a way that the
these vectors A are already sampled
uniformly at random so I need this part
to look very
uniform okay but um in order to if you
think about you know how is this um bit
V here distributed well V is a sparse
vector and well if R is like usually
pretty sparse then you know dot product
of two sparse vectors is um is usually
you know pretty close bias towards zero
so I want to make r as spse as possible
so that P is
small um and now okay so this is what we
want I'm running out of time uh so I
won't say too much more but basically so
um in this work I guess with Tom leish
we sort of um studied these kind of
smoothing bounds abstractly and in fact
you know if you have well for random
linear code basically you can get sort
of optimal smoothing bounds in the sense
that you basically the amount of sort of
um entropy that your sample needs is
roughly n minus K bits of entropy which
is sort of optimal since I need to you
know e modu my code which is you know
dist Over N minus K bits that should
look uniformly random and this is sort
of a statement with that holds with high
probability over random codes and the
proof um is basically just uh not worth
getting into and um we can also then
talk about nkd codes um and the main
sort of thing I want to leave you with
is that well we can sort of plug this in
and unfortunately we can't actually
really get any sort of improvements over
previous results and the previous
results are actually very disappointing
so basically in this this sort of
reduction we're able to show that say
it's hard to decode like log squared n
errors which perhaps you agree with me
is like technically not solvable in
polinomial time like you know you can
try your favorite algorithm and it well
Tech I think the best you can do is
probably two to log Square end time okay
so it's not solvable in polinomial time
then we can conclude that sort of I mean
I threw in some numbers I think these
are essentially correct um you know you
can't solve this version of LPN and
technically you know since I have an
inverse polinomial Gap from 1 half this
is solvable in a um Pol with polom many
samples but of course I don't think
anyone believes that this uh like from
my perspective I would say this problem
is way easier to solve than this problem
so you know I Prov that a seemingly easy
problem is if a seemingly easy problem
is hard then a seemingly hard problem is
also hard so it's a bit uh unsatisfying
I would say um and yeah maybe I'll just
leave sort of with a question maybe it's
actually impossible to do better with
this sort of reduction um and this would
sort of imply that so myself stop
here maybe in the interest of time we
can take questions
offline
so last up uh but certainly not least we
have uh roony Khan to tell us about read
Solomon codes versus deletions the epic
battle sorry I guess it doesn't say that
on the slide I assumed
that do
that so hi I'm I'm currently at uh at
the tech neon I just um did my PhD with
Amir Sak in t Aviv University and I'm a
post
doal working with
aobi and I'm going to talk about read
Solomon code versus uh
deletions and I'm going to jump right
ahead to the picture that basically
tells us what linear codes can do
against dels okay so jumping to the
broader picture of linear codes in
general not only code so uh okay so um
Chi and Lee recently basically initiated
uh This research saying that there are
good linear codes that can correct
conditions and by good I mean that if
you pick a matrix generating Matrix at
random then it can correct Delta
fraction of insertions and deletions
and let me just say just deletions for
this uh uh talk so it can correct Delta
fraction of deletions and have this rate
which is one minus that over two minus
this
thing
and they showed also two upper bounds
the first upper bound called half
Plotkin bound saying that basically you
cannot do much better than this you're
bounded by this term but what uh we'll
be focusing on today it's the half
Singleton bound which is just taking the
alphabet dependency out of here
basically saying that if you have a
linear code the best you can hope is
that your rate is going to be half one
minus Delta and this is the half single
ton bond this is in contrast to
nonlinear codes nonlinear codes achieve
the singl tone
bound um there's construction by hler
and
sharabi and and um so yeah linear codes
are provably not as good as nonlinear
codes in this setting and just a quick
remark it's not a rate distance tradeoff
it's a rate error correction capability
tradeoff okay uh this is because the
basically the Ed distance metric is from
zero to two Okay so basically when I say
like this uh inequality I mean that a
code can correct Delta fr of Del correct
not of a
distance um so what about read Solomon
code against insertions and
deletions so we've seen rean code a lot
in this right in this boot camp this is
the definition and also we can um
describe read Solon codes using the
generating Matrix which is the V Matrix
I write it this way though people write
it the other way around
um and right you take a message you
multiply uh by The vand Matrix and this
is equivalent to evaluating a degree at
most K minus one on alpha n up to Alpha
points and points and this these are the
points that basically uh Define a r
Solon code when I say read Solon code I
mean tell me the points
[Music]
um we love read Solomon Cod I mean yeah
we love not not just we in this room but
the entire world loves the read Solomon
code uh this is from essential coding
Theory okay the greatest code of them
all and well a lot of reasons all of us
know about this reasons so I don't need
this motivating slide basically but
let's focus on deletions and let's take
a closer look into a special case k
equals 2 k equals 2 we are looking
just lines okay our polinomial are
lines and we have this evaluation on a
line and if I want to tell you okay tell
me the polom you basically need two
pairs right Alpha I of alpha I Alpha J
and F of alpha
J but in this
work
second in this work I'm giving you this
information I'm giving you three
evaluations F of alpha i f of alpha J
and F of alpha s without telling you the
points Alpha I Alpha J and alpha s okay
I just tell you that okay so they are
ordered they come I mean that they
preserve the order from the code
word this is the only information and I
tell you learn F or
reconstruct and so this is
possible okay and there are couple of
Works about it uh
so this old table describes read Solon
code Dimension is
two they can correct n minus three
deletions so the single parameter that
can you know vary is just Q the alphabet
size so we started Duke at all started
and show the construction where Q is
exponential in
N then together with Amir and Saki we
showed a construction of where Q is n to
the four and we also showed a lower
bound of n to the three namely every
read Solomon code that can correct n
minus 3 delation two dimensional must
have this field
size and chronologically after our work
there's also this work that constructed
a different code of of field size n to
the five and
recently we uh closed
this for the k equals 2
case what about larger K situation here
is not that
good uh I I'm personally aware of only
one work that studied it
before that showed a code that can
correct this number of uh
deletions very small number but the
field size is very small
also um it's not I mean it's it's
generaliz
code and in the same work we showed two
things we showed an existence namely
there are read Solomon codes that can
correct from this amount of deletions
with this alphabet
size and also we constructed the r
Solomon code over much larger high Fe
this is n to the K to the K can correct
the same number of Del and why this
particular number matches the Singleton
bound okay so interesting in showing
that read Solomon K read Solomon codes
there are read Solomon codes that are
optimal achieve achieve what the best uh
um yeah
so yeah is this also with decoding or
efficient decoding
no it's purely information
the showing that the code has added
the K fixed here or can it also be n 10
or something what K can be like
proportional to n in this of K as fixed
uh n can be proportional but uh you know
even writing the points will take your
exponential time
so okay so it's not question yeah do you
also have a
lower so it's it's funny the lower Bound
for the k equals 2 case does not
generalize nicely to the K greater than
two and to be more precise for k equals
3 degrades to I think uh 2 and a half or
k equal 4 to2 and it's slightly
integ we eventually get for larger K we
get a lower bound of one so
yeah probably less
tight it's it's a really not good l b
but only for the the this only for this
case it's yeah evaluation points
arbitary here no I mean
okay
so here is an existence result
evaluation point there are some
evaluation points and here no the I I
tell you what are the evaluation
points so uh can I have uh do I have two
three minutes maybe two minutes two
minutes great so uh just just say a few
words about a condition that
implies
um implies Ron cause correcting deletion
so I'm looking at this huge Matrix which
I like to call it a double vandon Matrix
because it has two parts I part and J
part where I and J are basically
increasing sequences of
indices okay of length 2K minus
one and
and so this is a definition of sum
Matrix and I having I'm having the
following
condition I'm putting instead of the
formal variables I'm putting alpha 1 up
to alpha n and then I'm looking at the
must this Matrix this is a square Matrix
and I am claiming the following
thing if for every two increasing
sequences I and
J that agree on at most K minus one
agree pair is like
age it holds that this determinant is
non zero then the code can correct n
minus 2 k + 1
deletions and just to say a word about
the proof think that think of what an
element in the kernel looks like it
looks like a polinomial f is equal to
some polinomial G at some point Alpha I
equals Alpha G so F of alpha I equals g
G of alpha
J1 and you can think that there are here
a lot of agreements and this is
basically the LCS between two
pols okay so I want I want basically I
want it not to exist so if this
determinant is non zero for any such
configuration of I andj then I can say
that any two distinct polinomial the
evaluation do not share an Elis
of 2K minus one
L uh great open questions
so the the construction is really bad
it's the best that we could come with
but it's it's really exponential like
field size so and we know that you can
do n to the
K do it at TI tighter lower bound like
these two things are basically the same
question what is the right field size
for a read Solomon code that achieves
the half Singleton
bound uh decoding algorithms all of our
codes do not come with a decoding
algorithm and be super
interesting you know you could try all
the configurations
butal and I don't know maybe ltic
thank you all the things that you do
with the re Solomon in the classical
setting you can do with re Solomon in
the setting
um thank
[Music]
you do one quick question do you think
it helps to also go to like multi kind
of I
that's actually a good segue uh speaking
of open problems um into our next event
which is an open problem session but
first let us thank Rooney
again and let's thank all the speakers
uh in the speed talk
session and more clapping let's thank
all the speakers